foreign
during the Crusades these Warrior monks
battled for God gold and Glory
somewhere here in the modern city of
Accra lies their Command Center and
possibly their treasure
I'm here to find them
my name is Albert Glenn
and I look at the world in a unique way
I use 21st Century Technologies to look
back into our past
check that out I can actually fly
through the secret ancient world
[Music]
lasers that scan deserts
strip away dense jungle canopy and scour
the oceans to uncover the Hidden Worlds
beneath
we're waiting into uncharted waters
discoveries in the most awe-inspiring
places on Earth that's where pixels
become reality that fill the gaps in our
story who we are where we came from and
the Wonders we can achieve
here we are in the 13th century
[Music]
carved out of the earth huh this is the
new golden age of exploration
[Music]
[Applause]
the Middle East modern day Israel
the Mediterranean city of Accra it was
once one of the centers of the Christian
world and the Gateway between Europe and
Asia
during the first port of entry for
European pilgrims or Merchants you know
from every point on the compass
800 years ago
Maze of streets in this port city would
have been packed with a faithful on
pilgrimage to Jerusalem
many were wealthy far from home and in
need of Protection
security was provided by a powerful band
of devout but deadly monks
the Knights Templar
foreign
[Music]
Center and maybe their gold
is the stuff of my childhood dreams
[Music]
the first step is to figure out which
part of the city the Templars ruled
[Music]
I'm starting here at the church of Saint
Andrew
there's so many stories and places
associated with the Templars
ideas like how they might have possessed
earth-shattering sacred secrets
has taken the Templar to a weird place
somewhere between history
and Legend
thank you
yes that's so nice to meet you welcome
welcome this is beautiful this is where
the Templars actually hung out in here
no no no this is not the temple we are
in the right place but in a long time
let's go
down Benin beneath this church
[Music]
here this is it yeah under this door we
are going to see another world because I
got a movie right now are you kidding me
we're gonna go into a secret door behind
a junk shop
let's go
what
wow this is incredible now we are in the
right time in the right place here we
are in the 12th and 13th century this is
underground buried Crypt
this is really where the Templar was 800
years ago
[Music]
so creepy
I'm standing in a room
that ancient medieval knights the
Knights Templar
hung out in yes they live here more than
200 years
bet they never thought it'd be a bionic
foot on their floor
[Music]
this is the first floor of the building
but in the 13th century the Crusader
church was above us so we were just
standing a few moments ago in another
church right above me so there's Church
Upon Church yeah it's kind of crazy
because when you when you stand down
here it doesn't look all that different
from the church upstairs in terms of
style The Arches and everything yes but
if you are looking carefully the Templar
masonry were it's completely another
architecture
the stones are much bigger than the 19th
century building
then
it's very famous in the Crusader period
that a lot of stones as the masonry
remarks
so you see we hear this one oh yes
exactly this one this is actually the
mark of somebody's chisel
from the Templar
this is so cool
when you find something that you can
connect to the people that actually
built this building this is what's so
excited for me because you actually get
to the person yes exactly
[Music]
further below the modern city about 10
feet beneath the Crypt are more volts
secret Chambers
medieval knights Crypt
that's
we've established this was a Templar
building but I don't know what it was
used for
[Music]
wow
this is carved out of the earth huh
hello
what is this
is for collecting rainwater it's a huge
underground water tank
you can actually see the little Channel
where the water pours in from the rain
right there
the holy land is very very warm we are
in the Middle East and you need the
waters
Eliezer has excavated three of these 25
000 gallon tanks so far and he believes
there are many more
wow another one
where these kept secret these reservoirs
yes of course because they it's under
the ground so the enemy cannot find it
very easily and you have to remember
that this is a military order and they
are surrounding by enemy they can be
fold up in their quarters for as much
time as they need as long as they have
water all right
that's smart
this is an ingenious engineering feat
water depot
this must have been part of the Templars
area of control in the medieval city
the Crypt makes a good base for my field
lab
I'll map the existing Templar locations
and then maybe I can work my way to
where their Command Center could have
been
the ancient Crypt I'm in it lies here in
the southwest of modern Acra
next stop
a Templar location that has been
excavated it's 150 yards away beside the
harbor
here we go this way now in here it's
through this passage
10 feet below the streets
is a tunnel wow
this is incredible
whoa it was super far in there huh
we're really at the lowest level of the
city
the Templars because they had a lot of
money they wanted a secret passageway
for security to go from the port to
their water
and the Templars had a lot of gold they
collected from the pilgrims wait so
you're telling me that the Templar gold
moved through these ancient tunnels yes
it's safe to say that this is the case
wow exactly
it's incredible
we know their secrets no secrets can be
kept from the archaeologists
it goes on a long way
indeed it does
we excavated it for 270 meters so that's
roughly 900 feet of excavated tunnel
yeah
[Music]
what is this
you see this big opening see there yeah
what you see here is the guard room and
the guards sat here and controlled the
passage and you can see the holes in the
stone where the metal gate was and they
could put it down to shut and completely
close the passage like you would see in
my medieval castle that's so cool you
can imagine
so what's above us right now where are
we in the city here you see the lower
part of the street above us but where in
the city are we is there a feature above
us right now that you know is there
um I cannot tell you exactly
[Music]
you know the secret
far as the guard house
and that's got to be close to where the
Templars ran their operation
[Music]
GPS does not work on the ground so I'm
using a lidar scanner to record the
location of the Guard house
this is like a laser range finder like
the kind of thing you'd use to design
the inside of a house or to figure out
where you have to hit your golf ball on
a golf course but shooting a huge amount
of laser pulses
all those little points add together in
a 3D map
and what's really cool is that I've got
a team upstairs right now on the surface
in today's modern Acra
mapping the surface using drones and the
same technology
all this will make a 3D map of the city
above
and below
then we can see the secret tunnels and
the guard house will lead us into the
Templar zone of control
[Music]
now I have a landmark Underground
and once we connect this to the map
above
the positioning should tell me exactly
where the Templar quarter begins
on the streets above
foreign
we're getting close to identifying the
exact area the Knights Templar
controlled in Acura and it's thanks to
3D laser scanning
combine both scans above ground and
below and by combining the two
I gained superpowers
check that out I can actually fly
through both worlds now today's world
and then the secret ancient world
okay now I'm going to go beneath the
streets of Accra look at this descending
down descending down if there it is look
at that the subsurface I'm following my
below ground tunnel scan
3D map is a GPS for navigating above
and below ground
if we can find the guard house we'll
know exactly where the Templar quarter
begins
[Music]
according to this the guard house should
be that way
beneath me right now is the tunnel
moving its way up this alleyway
feels like I'm on a treasure hunt
[Music]
okay
this has to be it
I think I'm actually standing on it now
check this out ready
wow look at that
you can actually make out where the
secret tunnel sits right below the
surface here
the window
into the streets
look at that that's the that's the guard
house right there you can tell because
it's got the little tube that I climbed
into and scanned so this point marks the
edge
of the template quarter
I can see it
this is the first time anyone has
identified exactly where the guard house
lies under modern Acra
[Music]
following the tunnel scan has given me a
key landmark
the guard house
it looks like the Templar Zone begins
here
and then runs West
gold would have passed through the guard
house under these streets and gold is
the key to the templar's power and
prestige
I'm headed to Jerusalem let's check out
one of the world's largest hordes of
Crusader gold
[Music]
this is from a priest who is with the
first Crusader Army that arrive in
Jerusalem in 1099
says those who had few coins there here
possessed countless bissons
that's gold coins
so the priest is basically saying that
the Crusaders from Europe but they got
rich out here in the Holy lands
[Music]
thank you
foreign this Vault houses the world's
greatest Crusader coin collection
Dr Robert cool has allowed me access on
one condition
that I don't reveal exactly where I am
we in our collection have one of the
largest gold hordes that dates to the
Crusader periods
this is 4.02 grams yeah exactly pure
gold 24 karat gold
you don't find that kind of gold anymore
nowadays
and then how many coins are in this
trick we found 108 coins I
[Music]
was worth around
if you were a template you had to give
all your possessions to the order
all this money was for the defense of
the Holy Land
by necessity the Templars became very
very rich
there were no banks of course in the
modern sense so people used to deposit
their coins in these spots and if the
enemy came close you would bury it and
this is exactly what happened with this
pot so this was buried by Crusader hands
when they were under attack yes
it was found in a 13th century Castle
that is the only reason that I know that
this horde belonged to the Crusader
period because it was found in a
crusader Castle buried under the
floorboards exactly
it's a pretty dramatic story
1265 arse of Castle is invaded by Muslim
forces called mamluk
fleeing Crusaders buried their gold
including the very coins Dr Cool is
showing me
some desperate Souls take Extreme
Measures to smuggle out their fortunes
they would swallow their gold yes yes
written soils are full of stories of
people hacked to death just because the
enemy wants to see if they have gold in
their bowels you're kidding me that was
common practice in the Middle Ages it
would open their bodies just to be able
to see them so the person that buried
this gold
probably thought that he was going to
come back
as they came out of the castle they were
captured but the mom looks didn't find
this gold we found the gold
going to war even in the Middle Ages was
enormously expensive
probably the largest Templar Castle in
this area the castle of safety
just for building it they had to spend
one and a half million gold coins
and if you think that at the height of
their expansion the Temple's had I think
something like 58 castles here in you
know wow and they had hundreds of
castles in Europe does that mean that
there's more boards like this speckled
throughout the land hidden away under
the floorboards
possibly of course I mean gold is rare
but we constantly find hordes
in addition to the gold hastily hidden
at our surf all across the Holy Land
archaeologists have dug up coins
concealed within 53 Crusader strongholds
now we know what to look for the
Templars Command Center in Accra was
most likely an impressive Fortress
with a massive Vault to protect the
order's gold
[Music]
foreign
lost stronghold in the Holy lands
knowing that it's likely a fortress I've
done some digging
and I've come up with a journal from a
13th century writer the Templer of tire
it's his first hand eyewitness account
of Crusader Akra when it was Crusader
Akron how cool is that
and it describes a Templar Fortress
the strongest place in the city
it had at its entry a tall Strong Tower
and on each corner of the tower was a
huge Gold Lion
and also another very old tower on the
sea in which the Templars kept their
treasure
so by the Sea there's a fortress and a
treasure Tower
now I know I'm in the Templar quarter
there's only one way to the Sea
that direction
West
except what my 3D map indicated
thank you
it's not what I was expecting
it's a lagoon
[Music]
but you see these rocks in the line
right out there
it's hard to make out in the breaking
waves but there's something there
I want to take a closer look
but I think I'm going to need some help
[Music]
Marine archaeologist Edward galili has
spent half a lifetime scouring the
seabed around Accra
discovered a crusader shipwreck complete
with its anchor and something else
we were diving in the harbor the water
is dirty and Market
[Music]
to find Vulcan pottery and things like
this and suddenly we start to find gold
coins
so this is amazing
[Music]
investigations confirm this handful
hand pulled Thorns was minted in the
13th century during the reign of the
Templars
some fines are very exciting when you
find them it is not only the goal you
know it's the God and the story and the
whole presence of the Christian world in
the Holy lands
so it's important piece of History an
important archaeological fund
Earhart's gold coins were found here in
the entrance to the harbor where ships
more to unload pilgrims in cargo
their Hood believes his find may be part
of a bigger lost horde just waiting to
be discovered
if there is gold here the Fortress could
be near too
down here huh Don't Worry Be Happy
's knowledge of marine archeology and
the Crusader era make him the perfect
guide it's okay come all right trust me
on that
your average walk on the beach
[Music]
the route is precarious but Ed Hood
insists it will be worth it
[Music]
all right welcome shall we start going
let's do it
wow look at this it's so clearly
man-made this is a section of foundation
of a wall this is completely unique line
you can see that it is laid on the
Bedrock it is made of Ashley Stone you
can see sections of the wall over there
and most of his was ruined
these man-made Asher stones are cut and
dressed rocks shaped at a quarry just
like I saw in the Crypt
how do we know that it is Crusader
because we see here the holes they were
iron clamped go coming from here to here
to hold it like this and like this and
so on and so on it's kind of like like a
sewn Patchwork of stone yes
and this is the signature Crusader
buildings this is a cut from okay
because this is how they built the iron
clamps is a fingerprint of the Crusader
so what would have stood here in the
time of the Crusaders to set up all this
area was Crusaders
[Music]
you can see here a corner of the wall
you see that it is man-made and you can
still see the ashlands and here you see
the iron bath typical Crusader building
now this was a club it was like this
to connect the next Stone so you can see
this is clear evidence
it's very specific huh yeah of course
yes
there are some Scholars who claim that
some ruins are still left there that may
be associated with the foundation of the
Templar Fortress
wow amazing
[Applause]
how much would you pay to go back 800
years ago just to see at least one
treasure chest of Templar gold
as an archaeologist I am willing to give
you years of my life just to go and see
This Is The Stuff of childhood dreams
right
[Music]
the finding Fingerprints of the Templar
building design it's pretty awesome it
is somewhere hidden just beneath the
surface of this Lagoon is The Echoes of
this ancient Templar Fortress
the foundations in the lagoon have never
been mapped in detail
[Music]
drone will fly a grid pattern scanning
as it goes the resulting model will be
accurate to a sixteenth of an inch
[Music]
I'm hoping that this will prove that
these stones are not just sea walls
but the foundations of the Templar
Fortress itself
the foundation rocks in the lagoon and
Acura have been scanned
hoping the data will confirm that the
Templar Fortress once stood here
just got data now from the Drone that
scanned the entire Lagoon and what that
allows me to do here is by laying that
on top of reality I can enhance the view
of all the different rocks that Edward
had showed me
scan records the precise coordinates of
the remains
creating a 3D digital survey
this is the first time such detailed
scans of the Lagoon foundations have
ever been made
data needs to be interpreted so I'm back
in the field lab
using the traces of the foundation that
I just scanned you see these boom boom
boom I can actually begin to connect the
dots
that
now I've got my Seawall
and this
Templar Church Crypt which is right here
that would have been just on the outside
of the Fortress wall that would have
faced the city so something like this
and according to the description from
Templar of tire there were two towers
one at Each corner
now we know from the archaeologists that
today's Opera it was built on top of the
old city layer upon Lair and that it
would have been overlapping features
so the place that would have made the
most sense is where there's existing
material like where this Lighthouse now
stands right here
[Music]
and also over here where this collapsed
sea defense exists right here
so with all these pieces
I'm beginning to get a first pass at how
and where this long-lost Fortress might
have stood
[Music]
but if the Templar of tire was right and
the Fortress did guard a treasure Tower
data does not reveal where
[Music]
was another Crusader Fortress just 50
miles east of here and it's still
standing
maybe it'll shed some more light on this
deep in the heart of the Holy Land is
the site of Israel's best preserved
Crusader Fortress
this land those ones all Crusader
occupied they called it the kingdom of
Jerusalem
100 Years of the Crusaders their
boundaries it just kept on shifting As
Cities and fortresses fell as the armies
of the Middle East and
Christians of Europe battle each other
seder's Citadel still overlooks the
Jordan Valley
Belvoir Fortress
[Music]
its ingenious design was crucial to the
Crusader's survival
the man with the keys his daughter rabi
hamasi Ravi
hi hey thanks for meeting me
what I'm trying to do is piece together
the different elements of this Crusader
Castle to try to understand what that
Fortress model looked like in Akra this
is one of the most impressive Crusader
castles of the 12th century wow look at
this
massive
massive I are now standing on the
grounds in which an enemy would have
looked at the castle from their attack
yeah what would be going on they will
deal with something huge walls which are
few meters thick Above This there were
at least another two floors probably
another 14-15 meters high psychological
impact of seeing them and thinking that
I'm supposed to take this down it's a
big obstacle and it's not by a chance
that it held for such long period Under
Siege while there's nothing there
standing in hacker anymore I can start
to imagine how it would have looked
these outer Fortress walls give me a
sense of scale for Akron
but the key is the inner Fortress where
the treasure would have been held
it's confusing me I don't even know
where we're going now
if I can get in there
[Music]
to discover how Crusaders like the
Knights Templar Protected Their treasure
I've come to Belvoir Fortress in
northeastern Israel
here you're entering the main gate
okay I'm here I'm ready to fight and
then what happens you have to turn again
yeah there or maybe here or here
this is one of the most sophisticated
things that the Crusaders used to
prevent the enemy from storming the
castle
every time you are turning the Garrison
inside have more time to defend itself
it's confusing the enemy because you
don't know where you are going so it's
confusing me I don't even know where
we're going now
yeah exactly
where are we here now so we have the
double castles this is the nr1
double castles yeah we are exactly in
the center of the inner Castle how many
layers were there it's like an onion
kind of
[Music]
you have the mode it's the first line of
defense then you have the outer walls of
the outer Castle which is the biggest
one and then you have the inner Castle
's one inside the other functioning
together
but if the outer Castle filled to the
enemy the inner one can function alone
well that's some good engineering yeah
yeah that's really really sophisticated
[Music]
being here you kind of get in the heads
of the designers of the Crusader era
to look pretty it's designed as a
functioning system whereas you're
running in as an enemy you're being
forced to all these different channels
to have the longest possible route yeah
and all while you're running through
here you're being attacked by defending
all the time so it was designed for
confusion it was designed for fear to
create defense to create all these
different sort of scenarios that you can
keep the place safe yeah yeah
it's incredible
in 1187
Belvoir withstood a terrible Siege the
Towering walls and the vast underground
water tanks sustained the Crusaders
inside for one and a half years
ultimately
they were forced to surrender
Muslim leader Saladin spared their lives
The Fortress was prize enough
here I've seen the elements of a typical
Crusader stronghold
they were designed to keep attackers out
but also keep gold in
as the Crusaders move their fortunes
around Europe and the holy lands and
became bankers and these places they
were like um
ancient ATMs
but protected like Fort Knox
[Music]
I've got enough data now to reconstruct
the features of the Templar Fortress
[Music]
now working with the Crusader experts
this is how the footprints turned out
we're getting close now
I haven't gone to Belvoir it's I
understand the defensive structures to
protect the Crusaders but also their
gold
right here yeah located where I think
their treasure Tower should have stood
just like at Belvoir at its heart where
it's most heavily protected
[Music]
is where technology helps us
you can see this yellow line
that's the scan I did inside the secret
Templar tunnels and Edna's excavation of
those tunnels ends here
we know the tunnel went further
and if I just continue The Logical
trajectory of the tunnel I can complete
it
right there
look at that right in the middle of the
West wall facing the sea just like the
description of the Templar of tire
[Music]
what could that treasure Tower have
looked like
by digitally rebuilding the Templar
Fortress in Acura
we will finally be able to see for
ourselves
[Music]
I have returned to the site of the
Knights Templars Coastal headquarters
and I finally have enough evidence to
resurrect their great Fortress
okay I've combined together
all the elements the description from
the Temple of tire
the map of the footprint here that we've
waited out into the Lagoon to try to
find the observations from belvar
and by adding all those together
we get this
[Music]
look at that look at that right there
pouring right above us here would have
been a Templar Fortress
we've built an app that displays the
outline over the parking lot that stands
here now it's augmented reality
as I turn my perspective changes as if
the Fortress were really here
[Music]
hahaha
it's the first time I'm seeing this
the Reconstruction of what might have
stood here 800 years ago
it's the stuff of fairy tales and it's
all right here
like a ghost
full magnificent
deserved for those approaching by sea
[Music]
it's Mighty Sea defenses and Lookout
Towers stood against any invader
[Music]
while the templar's hidden tunnels
snaked beneath the streets
secretly transporting gold to the
fortresses crowning Glory
the fabled treasure Tower
[Music]
foreign
stronghold would have been a maze of
walls halls and ground Chambers
[Music]
giant carved Stones marked by Masons
proud of their craftsmanship
[Music]
great Gothic bolts would have arched
above epic Interiors
a monument to their holy war
[Music]
Fortress was the Colossal wealth and
power of the Templars manifested in
stone
they must have thought it would last
forever
The templar's Fortress and its treasure
Tower dominated this place for roughly a
century
that didn't last
in 1291 the mama looks besieged the city
collapsing the Mighty Fortress walls
that was the fall of Akra
the last Crusader Outpost in the Holy
Land
for the Templars
it was the beginning of the end
[Music]
so you remember the Templar attire
he wrote another eyewitness account of
the exact moment in which the mama looks
took down this city
known Fair Lords that no one could
adequately recount the tears and grief
of that day
the pitiful side of the little children
tumbled about and disemboweled
there's no man in the world who has so
very Heart of heart that he would not
have wept to see that Slaughter even
some of the mama looks had pity on these
victims and wept
[Music]
yeah well I kind of see it now you know
the Templars that made it out they fled
in haste
after the tunnels maybe to the port and
then out through the harbor
and like the Crusaders at Asura who
tried to hide their gold and these guys
they're trying to smuggle it out
maybe that's why there's never been any
gold in front of the Fortress
yeah the Templars
that moment they lost everything
except perhaps their Fortune
[Music]
remember those medieval coins that Ed
found right here in the harbor
well maybe they point the direction that
the templar's fortune went
[Music]
out there